I like um and I've always liked this I
like
asides when something's not planned and
they comment on how what the reaction
was or it's something really organic I
always like that in movies too where you
can tell it's not scripted because I
improvise a lot it's like reknown m1 was
all improvised everything I do I like to
improvise right so if there's something
that's just clearly and I can't ow if
just organically like you know they'll
be like oh uh yeah those kind of things
like those make me laugh I said like
somebody's just sitting there reppin
revenue all right that's it the bed you
know yesterday I was a just even a
line that's organic that's just part of
the the scene where did you just clearly
bacon you can tell I would always crack
up on Grandma's Boy because we would
make up so much stuff and we would do
stuff on the fly where I would throw
stuff out at Joel David Moore who played
JP was like the robot guy and I would
always throw stuff out at him and I
couldn't be in any scenes I would laugh
immediately because his voice was so
funny that was one of the hardest was
that was really hard to keep a straight
face and Kevin Nealon and Bucky Larson
there was a scene we could not get the
room it was the apartment apartment yeah
and we couldn't get through it and
people were and any actor comedian knows
this if you're in a scene in your
laughing and you get yelled at it makes
it worse because now you're conscious of
it and then now you can't stop laughing
if you're in a scene with a buddy and
reno 9-1-1
the most outlandish stuff i could to get
them to break to make them laugh so I
was always would just wrack my brain for
Terry insanity and it was great that I
would get them to break are you laughs
oh let's going back there having that
whole reunion thing or whatever because
every show is doing it in Reno 911
supposedly so why wouldn't they ask you
back that because would you do it I'm
not going back to Reno now on one
okay ad they asked me and I thought
about it and I just I love them and I
love the show but I just I spent my time
as Terry and the character had come full
circle with the end up with a movie and
everything I just it was just something
I want to just move on
forward and I've developing this new
show and uh you know I love Terry but it
was just something it was really a hard
choice it wasn't an easy choice but I'm
not coming back